Eu moro bem pra cheiro aqui, né?
É.
Tu vai se morrer logo?
Vou.
Cadê o cabo?
É 60 watts.
Quando eu tenho mais é...
Sabe o leite?
Sabe o leite.
Não tem jeito de fazer isso.
Enfim...
Tipo assim, não estou injustificado para essa conflito
Mas aí foi no meio da alimpíada
É só assim
Aquela do danquear mais que tu fez
Foi pior
Esqueci né?
Esqueci agora
Desperta e deixa ligado
Sim é, a informação ficou mais leve
Ah, deve ter aproxado o negócio
Tá um doido
Eu não tenho nada a ver com essa polícia.
É só um chá.
Você gosta de colocar...
Pega o bolso.
Fala aí, Fon.
Diz a atendado?
Não, eu não sei.
Ela é uma novice também.
Só que ela não chega pra mim.
Olha o Grinder
Você está bem?
Está triste
Vai se molhar não